people are flocking to Islam so me
seeing the argument of scientific
Miracles debunked it is debunked and
guess what we don't even need it
this app has been such a game changer to
me I've never been so consistent with my
Quran reading before I knew about Quran
League this is how people's lives are
changing and you can get qurani
absolutely free no credit cards for
seven day free trial what are you
waiting for download it now balloon
sisters and build a habit with the Quran
brothers and sisters and dear friends
okay so guys this is a quick video
inshallah I didn't want to do a
dedicated video to this I was here with
the brothers filming for the podcast and
for when I'm sat here I'll quickly uh
touch up on this quickly because it's
not really that important so in the
Android video that I did I mentioned
that the scientific Miracles
and for some odd reason funnily enough
like as if they thought that it was a
slip of the tongue I'll repeat it again
very carefully
the scientific miracles argument in the
Quran got debunked yeah I hope my touch
videos on points so when I said this a
lot of
um islamophobes were celebrating as if I
was like oh my gosh like this video is
going to be me apologizing and no listen
it got debunked now let's give some
context for some Muslims so they can
understand for example and I'll tell you
where this comes from and you know why
many people in the many Duart YouTubers
my colleagues like brothers that I
worked with didn't do a video why did
you say that because they know it as
well in what sense brothers and sisters
I was having a debate with a guy called
Phil yes this guy is a scientist or
whatever he is for that matter
I was debated with it I can remember
this very clear a couple of years ago
and I took an eye in the Quran which I
am not qualified to do which is give it
so there was an eye in the Quran who
says that there are seven heavens so me
I was claiming because this whole
scientific narrative that this is
talking about the ozone layer number one
is this Haram for me to do that why
because how can I give an understanding
to the Quran that Ayah with no
qualifications and who of you have ever
said that this is the ozone layer then I
was having a debate with this atheist
guy and trying to tell him that there's
seven ozone layers and he was saying to
me no my friend there are six ozone
layers and I was saying seven he was
saying six seven six seven six and we
say let's go to the NASA page so we went
to the NASA page an international page
guess what he said the argument was
apparently from the recent findings
whatever it may be this probably changed
and this is my whole point of the video
Yeah science changes it said that there
is five ozone layers
so I looked at him he looked at me and I
was thinking I'm saying seven you're
saying six NASA is saying five that is
where the penny drops for me do you know
why because we are making claims about
the Quran and specific verses and
because we was you know not myself I
would say but a lot of people were very
insecure because of the scientific you
know uh discoveries or whatever it may
be and we was trying to fit the
scientific narrative into the Quran
which was a big mistake because it's as
if as good as we were making science the
um the guideline for the Quran to be
accepted this is nonsense yeah we take
the Quran not science to hell with
science science changes tomorrow today
they talk about the Big Bang now there's
new uh studies or whatever new findings
that there was no big bank so my point
is what you cannot come and say this
word this verse here is a scientific
Miracle it's a scientific fact why not
because the Quran is wrong because
science changes number one number two
who told you that verse in the Quran is
talking about what you ascribing to it
simple as that so that's why I'll repeat
it one more time for my fans
the scientific argument scientific
Miracles the Quran is debunked and we as
Muslims guess what it doesn't bother us
to the least you know why because
alhamdulillah you know what's very
interesting people are flocking to Islam
isn't that crazy all you mortars you
ex-muslims all you hostile Christians
islamophobes not all of you zionists
some of you are Jews some of you Hindus
all of you guys have got your Tails
between your legs walking away and you
know what's interesting people are
coming to Islam because of his
intolerance what happened to you know me
singing that and we are proud of that
and I'll repeat it again yes we are
proud of that yes and you know what I'm
talking about alhamdulillah in Islam
there is that capital punishment we are
proud of that alhamdulillah every
legislation
we are proud of that and I know you're
watching this and biting your tongue out
of your things out of Rage that Allah
says in the Quran die in your rage
millions and thousands of people are
coming to Islam alhamdulillah what
happened to all your arguments of Islam
is treats woman Islam says this
punishment for ex-muslims Islam says
look how bad it is
people are still flocking to Islam
alhamdulillah
it's as simple as that and we praise our
Lord not Allah says when people are
coming to multitudes to Islam
alhamdulillah we praise all your efforts
that you did for 10 years it's all gone
in the bin or even the recycle bin you
can't even recycle it it's gone to the
waist like two it's gone people are
flocking to Islam so me seeing the
argument of standing Miracles debunked
it is debunked and guess what we don't
even need it we don't even need it
alhamdulillah so an example and and
Nasir to give to all of you guys
alhamdulillah it's very simple you do
not read into the Quran we do not make
that mistake by reading and this verse
means that now
is there certain facts for example when
Allah talks about the depths of the
ocean wherein if you put your hand up
there are layers and layers of Darkness
we can see wow that is very interesting
because now recent discoveries do show
that so I'm not saying totally you can't
use it but I'm saying to use science as
a yardstick this is wrong the Quran is
our yardstick we don't say because the
science changes one day he says this
next day he says that it's as simple as
that so that's the reason why we say
there are strategies in the Quran which
is like how could a man know this if it
was from a man not from God who went to
the deaths of the ocean yes thousands of
meters down to know that blessed day is
the layers of Darkness that is my point
so once again for all my fans out there
islamath Falls the cowards the little
weasels Islam is growing yes okay for
those who like Muhammad says who are
intellectually molested yes it is
debunked and we don't need it
alhamdulillah Islam doesn't mean
anything and people are flocking to
Islam our Tower videos people are
accepting
that's all I wanted to say alhamdulillah
and brothers and sisters may Allah bless
you guys inshallah till next time
what what
foreign